Zoos have changed
out of all recognition.
There are quite a lot of different
species around the planet,
which we wouldn't have today
if it wasn't for zoos.
What do you think an ideal zoo
would look like?
Closed.
All through history, we've seen
royal families,
powerful people, emperors,
have collections of animals.
The king who was a good hunter
was probably a good warrior,
probably protect his people.
Killing a lion or a bear
was a big deal,
but bringing back a live one
showed even more power.
Virtually all the history of zoos
is about human control of nature.
And it was a way of showing off.
Queen Charlotte, her gift to everybody
that she liked
was to give them a kangaroo.
And eventually we get the first
modern zoo opening in London in 1828.
To be able to suddenly see
a giraffe for the first time,
probably it was absolutely bonkers.
There wasn't really an appreciation
of animals needing certain things
to have a good life.
So you would see them in barren
boxes, effectively,
just as you would see a specimen
in a natural history museum.
JON COE: The story was, here's an object
divorced from habitat,
divorced from evolution.
His name is, by the way,
knucklehead.
Knucklehead?!
Well, as a rule, tapirs
are rather stupid and unintelligent.
Animals were thought
of as basically automatons
just responding in a reflexive manner,
with no feelings of pain
or any kind of emotional depth.
But that's really shifted.
Now there's much
more of an understanding
that we really need to look
at their own type of intelligence
and how they live in their world.
The schoolchildren that come
here to the wildlife park,
all of them go away learning
the messages that we know for sure
are going to make a true difference
to the animals
back out into the wild.
The biggest threat to wildlife comes
from people,
and most people live in cities.
So zoos are very important because they
provide an educational opportunity
for people to learn about what the impacts
of their daily activities are
in far away places.
JON COE: The zoo, by becoming a public
attraction, if it's done properly,
it seems to me like a pretty good idea.
The animals have a good life.
People enjoy it. They learn something.
Hopefully they get involved
in conservation.
JON MINION: Pretty much all good zoos
throughout the world
are participators, or they help
to support and fund a whole host
of in-situ conservation programmes.
And if it wasn't for those programmes,
the world would be looking
very different right now.
Zoo populations of animals are insurance
populations.
Certain species,
due to what's going on on the planet
at the moment,
the only way that we can stop them
from going extinct
will be to bring them into captivity.
As we learn to adapt to things
like climate change,
we are going to see an increasing
role for zoos.
You can visit zoos all over
the world that are just awful.
You know, they're as bad
as they were in the 1920s.
ROBERT YOUNG: In the US they don't have
very strict animal welfare laws.
People can have animals in their back
garden and call it a zoo.
There are more pet tigers in the US
than there are tigers in the wild.
The legislation doesn't permit
that kind of thing here in the UK,
but you can get bad zoos anywhere.
Those are all signs that they're missing
out on some important aspect
of how they live in the wild.
The complexity of providing a good life
for some of these animals,
it's actually really, really difficult.
There is some evidence that people
will know more facts
about a particular animal, for example,
but follow up studies to see if they've
actually changed their behaviour
to benefit conservation,
there's not much evidence
to suggest that is happening.
The official statistics show that 4% of
revenue goes back into conservation.
I mean, that's minimal. That's very small.
And what do you find in zoos?
Big cats and elephants and zebra
and things that don't get released
back into the wild.
So if you want to save the condor,
then you can have an in situ
conservation programme
that's based in the country
where they come from.
Most five year olds
are experts in dinosaurs.
They've never met one or seen one.
The fascination's there,
and I think the same can be
harnessed with animals.
There's many other technologies that are
being developed these days,
like awesome CGI, awesome robotics.
I think the future holds
something really cool
in the sense of learning about animals
without the detriment
of keeping them in captivity.
Virtual reality with wildlife
encounters is really coming on.
Taking a virtual walk through a herd of
elephants in the Serengeti,
I think, is going to be possible
pretty soon.
Do you think zoos should exist?
It's kind of strange that
we transport all of these animals
from far from home
and keep them locked up
where you should see what nature
has to offer on your doorstep.
Wildlife documentary, virtual reality -
none of these things have the same
positive emotional impact that a zoo has.
10% of the global population
visit zoos every year.
People from all walks of life
and all social classes.
So, I think, without zoos,
we'd lose a massive opportunity
to keep people being interested in the
wild environment.
How can we create a world
where we don't need zoos?
What I'm hoping is that we can
design super sustainable cities
so that you don't need to go
to a place to see animals.
They're all around you.